NWA has a biographical picture still
waiting on my NKOTB biographical picture
but I'll take this Straight Outta
Compton so Straight Outta Compton is the
biographical picture of the group NWA it
really concentrates on the three main
characters of NWA who are Ice Cube dr.
Dre and eazy-e
by some good talent fine guys did a good
job not just the main stars like a
little cameo artists that are in this
movie that played younger versions of
artists you know they either look like
or look and act like the people they're
portraying it's really it's almost scary
just proves me that time travels real it
did like the Bill and Ted they just went
back into the past like hey come with me
let's be in a movie as young you of
course or well but in this movie this
group of friends are from Compton they
have big dreams you know they write down
lyrics and rhymes I want to make rap
music the cops will rough them up for no
reason whatsoever learn three black guys
on a street corner they must be slinging
dope so then they form the group and
they start getting more and more famous
and it just hits the media I mean what
these people did to the music industry
was a huge thing people from that walk
of life didn't have some didn't have a
voice if you're like oh look at that
Beach Boys just came out with their new
album and I guess Kokomo is a great
place that's relatable for me then these
guys hit is a holy [ __ ] but it was
important nonetheless because it was a
voice I mean it's like one of the main
things the backbone behind a lot of
their music was in fact these cops were
just rough him up so like yeah [ __ ] the
police oh they made that song it was
just this huge sting like I catch pretty
[ __ ] up and they can't say that about
the police good day sir but sir I said
good day sir
and it got on the map a lot of other
artists that you know in rap I mean odds
are if there is a rap artist out there
it was really big he somehow was
influenced by dr. Dre if you still don't
know who dr. Dre is he's the one who
wanted to shoot ethan hawke in training
day that's your simplified version I
really dug this movie though man I saw
it with a crowd when the music would
start playing it would hit in the movie
they would start singing along to the
lyrics usually that [ __ ] irritates me
but it was just such an energy in the
auditorium everyone was having a good
time with this movie it actually
improved the experience but not the
experience would have been bad I'm just
saying there was a lot of positive
energy in the room and I love that [ __ ]
this movie really hit me it was great to
see these pioneers in this movie go you
know what I see this and I'm gonna sing
about this anything that rattles the
cages of the conventional usually I'm
there for that because I like that [ __ ]
look at the different characters in this
movie got time to shine at first I was
like oh this movie is all about eazy-e
that's interesting I didn't know it was
gonna be like that but here we are and
then you're like oh wait it's about Ice
Cube that's interesting okay so now with
the movies about Ice Cube know now we're
on to dr. Trey okay now we have dr. Dre
I mean they all have screen time
together but different sections
different chapters of the movie
concentrating on different people and
that's a great way to tell the different
sides of the story and you just get a
whole well-rounded picture in there 100%
accurate I don't think so personally
there are some things you can look up
and read about your life that's just no
we're in this movie and it does make
sense as dr. Dre and Ice Cube they both
produce this movie and so they have
their say in the movie and they're like
we're still out there doing stuff we
don't want to we don't wanna look like
dicks maybe we did some dumb [ __ ] when
we were young let's just kind of not
show that near times change people
change that's one of the things I liked
about this movie also is you have you
take three guys from the same
neighborhood they have the same career
path you give them a lot of money and
they're gonna end up in different places
in a few years that's what this movie
shows and it does illustrate that
there's no precondition to it's like you
can take someone from a neighborhood
give him a lot of money he's going to
end up here take someone else from that
same neighborhood give him a lot of
money he's going to end up there some
end up a good place to some end up a bad
places but you just you forge your own
destiny in the end guys Straight Outta
Compton really impressed me I enjoyed
the [ __ ] out of this movie I loved the
music I loved the vibe whether or not
everything that might be skeletons in
the closet is in this movie or not it's
irrelevant because the movie is damn
entertaining it has the fields when it
needs to there are two scenes in
particular I straight up man teared the
[ __ ] out of my eyes I'm saying Straight
Outta Compton is worth watching and
worth buying on blu-ray right guys so
Straight Outta Compton have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you